et les quelques chaque fois qu'on vous
voit réapparaître sur cet écran pour
chanter on a l'impression d'assister un
miracle un miracle qu'on attendait plus
d'où vient cette force ce courage qui
vous tire toujours des plus mauvais cas
là je pense que c'est la fois à la fois
en tout vous croyez à la chance je crois
je crois tout simplement la destinée ne
crois pas là dit si je crois que les que
les bonnes choses aillent si on le
désire
je crois qu'on peut se sortir de
n'importe quelle mauvaise situation dans
votre vie jamais vous ne vous êtes dit
lorsque vous étiez malade par exemple on
lit qu'il y avait des limites et que ses
limites vous l'aviez franchie c'est à
dire quand on est malade évidemment
c'est très dur d'avoir pour moral mais
tout de même ce même si je et m'est
arrivé de me laisser abattre un petit
peu immédiatement jeu reprenait le
dessus
non c'est pas possible m'en sortir j'y
arriverai votre vie a été plutôt
désordonnés tourmente et d'autres
artistes en sont plus ménagé de leur vie
est-ce que vous pensez que si vous les
aviez imiter ou courrier les jours plus
tranquilles au probablement je pense que
je n'aurais pas donné ce que j'ai est ce
que j'ai donné au public que je pense
que comme tout ce que c'est je t'aime
qu'il s'agisse d'un entièrement vous ne
croyez pas aux économies
ah non surtout parmi les moralement ni
matériellement et oui c'est ou pas on ne
pensait pas la vieillesse par exemple
non quand elle arrivera le père à qui
vous avez peur de la mort vous avez eu
peur
on ne t'a pas de la mort j'avais pensé
j'y ai pensé et je l'accepté ccd dû
arriver
je pense que j'étais prête aussi l'une
de vos chansons vous avez chanté il y un
an
simple et je ne regrette rien vous
l'avez chanter ici à cinq colonnes
c'était une chanson qui a bouleversé les
gens parce que on croyait que c'était de
vous parliez pas ce que c'était de vous
vous parliez lorsque vous jugé votre vie
est ce que vraiment vous ne regrettez
rien et où par exemple faire exactement
la même façon chanteux toujours l'amour
et on sait que pour vous l'amour n'est
pas comme on n'est pas seulement un
thème de chanson qu'est ce que vous
attendez qu est-ce que vous avez attendu
de l'amour et du bief
mais ce qu'il m'a donné c'est à dire le
merveilleux triste le tragique
l'extraordinaire des déceptions aussi
je n'ai jamais été déçu vous ne vous
êtes jamais dit que l'amour les chansons
au sein d'un canton qu'est ce qu'il y
aura après pour vous je ne sais pas
il y aura toujours quelque chose vous
posez pas la question
beaucoup de vedettes vous doivent leur
carrière ne vedette aujourd'hui des
hommes d'ailleurs surtout qu'est ce qui
vous pousse à aller lancer parce que je
pense que je devine à travers les est je
crois que j'ai ce ce sens de double vue
même si personne ne le voie moi je sais
que deux ans après je vois le personnage
tel qu'il sera c'est un peu la même
chose pour vous découvrir quelqu'un ou
découvrir une chanson oui ces régions
tout ça c'est ça se retrouve aujourd'hui
encore vous avez découvert quelqu'un
dont il est découvert un garçon qu'il y
a deux mois encore n'avait jamais chanté
de sa vie et qui était venu pour
travailler comme secrétaire
là il n'était pas doué du tout je les ai
vus tout de suite et puis comme il était
très sympathique mais j'avais posé des
question j'ai essayé de reconnaître et
puis je les fais un jour chanter je me
suis rendu compte en le faisant
travailler c'est un garçon qui pouvait
faire quelque chose de très bien à la
chanson mais non seulement il est
dépassé mes espoirs militaire et une
rapidité folle vous avez chanté avec lui
oui comment s'appelle cette chanson la
chanson s'appelle à ça sert à quoi
l'amour et lui s'appelle théo sarapo
[Musique]